Okay. Thank you, everybody, for being on today's Zoom call.
We're going to have a quick announcement, a couple of announcements,
and then I do have a few great questions that came through.
I should have time at the end for other people to submit questions on to the chat.
So, starting with a couple of announcements.
First of all, Dr. Connor's did mention this last week,
but we have moved. We've relocated.
So we are needing people who are going to be shipping in cheek swabs for follow up testing to be sent to our warehouse,
which is at Dr. Kevin Conners, 2261 State Road 35.
Bad my part that I'm getting auto crux all the time. It is not warmer set.
It's summer set, so I'm going to type it into the chat summer set Wisconsin.
So if you need to copy that and add that into your notes, that is where you will send your cheek swabs to is our warehouse.
And then for in clinic appointments, that is going to be determined.
So we have yet to establish at the clinic are exact hours right now at the new space.
We're still trying to get everything set up. So if you are local and are needing to come in for therapies or to do thermography supplement pickups things like that.
Please call us at our number 6517391248.
I'm going to actually start with a question and then through that we've got a great announcement.
So the first question that came through is have you ever heard of the book and healing methodology espoused by Dr. Alexander Lloyd in the healing code.
If so, what is your opinion and experience with the effectiveness of this protocol for addressing stress and healing emotional and spiritual issues.
I've heard of this book. I have wanted to read it. I've not had a chance to.
Speak to it with any sense of authority.
I, I've heard, I've heard really, really great things.
What I can at least speak to is what we do offer on our website as far as emotional support.
And that is the workbook and paperback book written by a friend and fellow practitioner of Dr. Connors and myself.
Her name is Megan Vanzeel and it's called braving the storm. We do offer this bundle. You can buy either the book, the workbook or the two of them as a as a bundle on our store, the bundle as you can see here is about 51 dollars.
So it's, it's excellent. She, her really her entire platform is is based around the organization or the business that she created called cancer piece university.
And it is coming alongside people to help them as they walk through this journey.
She has helped so many of our patients. A lot of her clients that she has worked with have ended up coming to work with us as patients.
We have developed a really great working relationship with her over the years she's lovely.
The announcement then is in accordance with cancer piece university, Megan Vanzeel is doing a change your cancer story micro summit that micro summit did start today.
And there are I believe there are five different well known doctors or entrepreneurs that she has drawn into this summit and there is a new interview each day.
Dr. Connors is one of the ones who was interviewed for her mini summit or her micro summit. And you can find out information on how to sign up for it and listen by going to change your cancer story.com.
So again, change your cancer story.com for this micro summit.
It's attendance is free to sign up for it. And it's a great way if you are interested in doing some emotional work and would like to get a chance to kind of see what some of these other practitioners are talking about and then also Megan's perspective on this and kind of get a feel for Megan's personality and what she's all about this might be a great option for you.
I'm not sure if she's doing a 24 hour replay once the first one has has aired and it's meant to be in more of a podcast form so you listen to it as opposed to watching it.
But she's she's great. And so we highly recommend signing up for this so go to change your cancer story.com go ahead and sign up for that. And then again, she's with Cancer Peace University. That's her business.
Next question that came through I have dry skin and dry mouth. What can I do? What is the issue. Well, first as far as what is the issue. There can be a lot of health concerns that can lead to dry mouth.
And so I'm not going to be able to give you a guarantee on what the issue is. That's why we do testing in our clinic is so that we instead of guessing on what might be tied to it. We could probably do a cheek swab and do some testing and see what might be going on. But one of the major reasons why somebody might be dealing with dry mouth is simply dehydration.
But a lot of people get dehydration wrong and that they think the way to solve dehydration is just by drinking more water, but there's a greater balance that happens with that if you are drinking a ton of water during the day, you can actually make yourself more dehydrated than if you do a combination of drinking water as well as consuming cellular support products and consuming minerals.
So our recommendation is that if you're dealing with dehydration and you're drinking a lot of water, or you believe you're drinking about as much as you can tolerate.
Our recommendation is to add in some minerals or pink Kimmelane sea salt. Our most robust mineral supplement that we offer on our website. It's clear.
Multi-min plus and I'll add that in on the chat right now.
The second item that I have on this list is phosphatidecoline. Phosphatidecoline is a lipid which helps to specifically protect your phospholipid bilayer, which is the fatty membrane that supports the outer exterior of your cells.
When you deal with chronic inflammation or chronic states of dis ease in the body, you can destabilize your cellular membrane.
Well, when you have a destabilized membrane, it makes it difficult for you to be able to maintain a healthy intracellular and extracellular water balance.
And so taking a product like phosphatidecoline or a product that contains phosphatidecoline in it can be very helpful in protecting the the structural fortitude of your cell membrane and can prevent you from losing that valuable intracellular water balance.
The third item actually I'm going to put on the chat. The product that we carry is our body bio PC and PC stands for phosphatidecoline that is the option it comes in both liquid and a large horse pill like capsule or a gel capsule.
The third item on this list is dry brushing so one of the issues that that why people often have dry skin is that through their heightened detoxification process they're not sloughing enough dead cells off of their body.
And so if you can do dry brushing that helps with that process of sloughing off those dead skin cells and allows newer skin cells to be getting the oxygen that they need to be able to actually absorb any kind of moisture if you do choose to add moisture to your skin.
And it's just going to be able to help you to also let your skin naturally sweat a little bit better you won't get as clogged of pores things like that. So dry brushing can also help with them fatic flow, which is ultimately going to help with your overall detoxification process.
So my recommendation is to start on the error on the side of dehydration adding in some minerals, maybe some phosphatidecoline and then if you wanted to do something topic I would say don't add more oils oils tend to be especially regularly applying thick oils onto your skin that actually prevents your skin from breathing.
And so, and from sweating and from getting that correct amount of oxygen and interaction with your environment so I tend to recommend starting with dry brushing and if after dry brushing your skin feels incredibly dry and you've been working on your dehydration, then there may be some things that you could do topically to help with alleviating that issue.
Next question about HCG tests if you can tell from doing a special HCG urine test and track any cancers progression why couldn't you find treatments that target those cells that produce that special hormone there is a basic cell related to all cancers right.
Well, that's so that's an interesting question. So for those of you who might be new to our program we offer a or I shouldn't say we offer but we're connected to a laboratory and clinic in the Philippines called the Navarro Medical Clinic.
And Dr. manual D Navarro senior who is pictured up here in the right hand side he invented a non invasive tumor marker test called the Navarro HCG test which tests for the hormone HCG in the body and if somebody isn't pregnant or menstruating it can help with tracking
cancer cell progression or potentially the presence of cancer cells. So for some of our patients who don't have access to a general practitioner or are just looking for something to do in addition to tumor markers they may be running through their general clinic.
This is a urine test and it's a fairly simple option. So what I want to correct about this understanding is that it's not that there are specific cells which produce HCG or are connected to HCG based upon Dr. Navarro's research and he was an oncologist the research that he found was that all types of cancer cells
either produce or are tied to HCG and so through that he was able to find that you could do this almost as a preventive so he was considering it to be even an option instead of screening that instead of going and maybe getting a colonoscopy or going in for a mammogram that you could simply send in a urine sample to him.
And through him testing that urine sample could see if there's an elevated spike in HCG and if there is then that might be a reason to go in and do additional screening elsewhere or additional testing to see if there actually is a presence of cancer.
So it's not that there are specific cells that we can target due to an HCG test. It's simply that we have found a correlation between a higher presence of HCG in the body and a presence of cancer cells or cancer cell activity.
The second question that was here is does rife have frequencies for that special HCG producing cell so getting into the same component is that based upon our testing we are testing for frequencies that are correlated for your type of cancer.
It's not that type of cancer is the only cancer that's producing HCG. It's appears based upon Dr. Navarro's testing and I've not seen a lot of countering research that is completely negating that but based upon the research that he did it's that all types of cancer cells can increase that HCG hormone.
If you would like to learn a little bit more about that process so you can understand how he came to develop his clinic and what HCG is and does in the body, I recommend checking out their clinic, which is Navarro Medical Clinic.com.
They have a good amount of information. It's not a huge website. They keep it pretty simple, but he's been his son who's down here in the lower left hand corner. He runs the clinic now and he has been great to interact with so has been very good to us.
Next question. Can I eat rabbit regularly. So this kind of gets into your specific dietary recommendations. So do know that when I'm making these recommendations, if you are able to eat this or not able to eat this, just know that I'm not giving the go ahead for every single person we have to tailor it down to what your protocol protocol binder says specifically.
So per the culinary arts rabbit meat is considered a form of white meat based upon how it's prepared and served so white meat is typically considered meat from either fish or from chickens. However, scientifically or biologically speaking rabbit meat is considered red meat and that's based upon its chemical makeup.
But if you are worried about whether or not you can eat it, you want to go back to your binder then and we base our recommendations upon the idea that rabbit is a red meat.
You would want to go back to your binder and see what we have placed in your binder for red meat recommendations. If you're to avoid then maybe eat rabbit on a holiday or on a very special occasion, if it's to limit, then we usually say maybe eat rabbit.
Anywhere from one to three times in a week, no more than that. If it says that yes, you can eat red meat. We still don't typically recommend eating red meat three squares a day, but somewhere within a balance for you to be able to eat some more red meat. Now I do want to be
very careful in recommending eating a lot of rabbit all the time, even though it can be very good rabbit meat has a much higher protein content per serving than most other types of meat out there higher than beef turkey.
And so if you're only eating rabbit and I don't know anybody who's only eating this at this time, but I know that people who do a lot of small game hunting and trapping may be eating rabbit.
So you just want to be very careful about eating it exclusively, especially if you're not consuming higher amounts of grains and other fruits and veg to balance that out, but for people that are on a really high diet that consists mostly of rabbit because they're trying to get in high protein.
There is a condition called rabbit starvation or what is technically it's protein poisoning because rabbit is so lean, it has no fat in it that your body is just getting high uptake of protein all the time.
Other meats like beef and chicken, they tend to be a little bit fattier, especially fish to fish has a nice fat content.
So that's more of a well rounded meat presentation. So if you're going to eat rabbit, just make sure that you're combining it with a lot of other food options.
Next question. Hi, due to an oxalates issue in which many supplements have oxalates, I am so confused about what to take and not I haven't been taking turmeric after consulting with my liaison, but due to inflammation you guys said increase my turmeric, I assume she forgot I wasn't taking also confused about vitamin C as it can metabolize into oxalates, please help.
Okay, so this has to do with a genetic review.
Those of you who are newer to starting with us, you will likely not have done your genetic review as I'm going through this, so if it doesn't make sense, you can certainly take down some notes, especially if you're familiar with oxalates, but just know that a lot of this sort of dietary component will be covered when we go over your custom genetic report.
So I'm going to make one thing very clear for everybody else who has done their genetics and has any concerns about the dietary recommendations that were made based off of your genetic profile.
And rule number one is that cancer recommendations that we either make in this office or that we utilize via kinesiology testing.
Trump's everything else so your genetics, what we read on your genetics is secondary to what we recommend or what we test you for regarding cancer, unless there's a very, very small unless if there is a significant allergy that's involved.
Or there are severe symptoms that are noticed after consuming that particular ingredient or food otherwise, if you have been tested for, we'll just say turmeric or vitamin C for what you're dealing with with the cancer, we're trying to keep you alive.
And by helping your immune system fight this cancer, we're much more concerned about that than we're concerned about whether or not you have a single or double allele defect in a gene that might make it difficult for you to handle oxalates that could render you at a higher propensity for things like kidney stones.
So remember that your genetic defects and I talked about this in a previous zoom call your genetics are laid out like a irrigation system it's very complex and there are a lot of small moving parts but it moves together as a system.
And as you clean up your genetics as a whole as your detoxifying and eating better and trying to make some minor changes based upon the recommendations that we have made your whole irrigation system is going to begin to operate better and better and better.
Our goal is for you to have balance with our genetic recommendations not perfection balance is much more important than perfection and if, if getting rid of the supplements that we have tested you for that would be beneficial for something like inflammation or beneficial for something like helping your body to actually fight cancer.
If getting rid of those things is what's happening for you to think that you're taking our genetic recommendations seriously, then we're kind of missing the boat on that when you're to be reducing oxalates that's all that you're to do is just to reduce.
In general, the constant consumption of oxalates or at least to monitor your symptoms the most common sign of people who have an issue with clearing oxalates is that they have kidney stones or that they have that in their family lineage mom and dad had you know my mom had kidney stones or my dad had kidney stones well it's likely that you've inherited that a real defect.
And so that's the most common sign but if you've never had kidney stones or you don't have them currently being absolutely perfect in eliminating all oxalates from your diet doesn't necessarily make sense often the reason why a double allele defect in a particular you know genetic sequence can become a problem is because a lot of the other supporting genes.
that are either helping it to function or clearing its effects are also pretty dirty and they're just not cleaned up but usually somebody is able to just take a minor step back from the amount of oxalates they're eating and can usually handle that without too much of a problem but it's important for you to track your symptoms.
So if you have an existing kidney disorder or just or if you have kidney cancer gout or rheumatoid arthritis and you notice that if you eat foods that are higher in oxalates that that can cause those symptoms to get worse then yes definitely being more strict and lowering your oxalate intake is going to be a good idea we do have a supplement that does assist with that.
It's called oxalates scavenger so that you're not getting rid of all of the fruit and veg that contains oxalates as you can see here over 90% of the fruits and vegetables that are out there contain oxalates so if you were to try to get rid of them you'd be you'd be eliminating me again like a lot of a lot of the ingredients that are out there.
You would essentially be eating ice chips so again we want to have balance we don't want to have perfection I would rather see somebody reduce some of their dietary options so that they can maintain a better balance in.
Some of the supplements that are coming up not every single supplement again i'm not here to push supplements on you but I am saying that my role an hour role as a clinic was to test you for supplements that could assist your immune system in doing what it was supposed to do in the first place prior to you being diagnosed with cancer so.
So we've had a lot of patients who've come to us and said you know I really I just want to get off of all of my supplements I just want to tighten up my diet and and really focus on getting all of my nutrients from my diet I've had many patients who said that and I said you go you go right ahead and you do that i will tell you probably nine times out of 10 that individual will often end up coming back to us and saying okay.
Things are getting a little bit worse what do you think that I can add in to try to support my system because unfortunately what we're dealing with right now in society is a complete degradation of our food supply in every way from the fertilizers that we use to the way that we just farm our soil and repeatedly rape it year and year after year after year.
It's just in the GMOs and the hybridization and all of the things that we do that destroys the nutrient content in our food if we're dealing with a major state of dis ease like cancer we may not be able to completely write the imbalance in those scales just through diet alone we may need some additional help so.
As I was saying previous.
My recommendation would be if you can tighten up a little bit on the diet side so that it would allow you to eat take your supplement that has turmeric in it to help you with decreasing your inflammation and your pain.
Or that would allow you to take that vitamin C so you can improve your bodies immune response against the cancer, then I would go in that realm as opposed to wiping out the supplement completely that you've been tested for and trying to just focus on diet and hoping that that's going to take care of it all you can if you want but then get back to me if any of those symptoms change for the worst.
That's the end of the questions which came in I did see a couple of questions come through on the chat question I am water fasting today pre chemo is much a tea or chaga tea both medicinal considered supplements or should I avoid them.
No if it's just much a powder or chaga powder I see no problem in you taking them you're not really getting a high caloric intake it's not going to spike your your glycemic index or blood glucose levels so I I don't see why you can't drink that tea that sounds good to me.
Next question can HCG in blood test also give same results as a urine test they so Dr. Navarro did that exact study he ran a study where he took I believe it was 32 patients that had cancer diagnosed and he ran a urine test to test for HCG and he ran a blood test to test for HCG.
31 of the urine samples came back with a correct HCG reading in the positive range and only I believe 12 of the blood samples came back as a reading so the accuracy of doing HCG via urine is much higher than doing it with a blood sample.
Next question chemo supplement rotation protocol is full spectrum CBD 100 milligrams but I cannot find that on Connor's store is this just a basic supplement I can pick up at my co-op or where do you recommend we purchase a good clean brand.
Yeah so it's it's just a general recommendation a full spectrum CBD means that it has a very small trace amount of THC in it we do have a couple of different CBD options on our store but if you can get a brand that is organic from your local health food store or from a trusted dispensary I would highly recommend.
Going there and doing that I'm not strict about who you get your exact CBD from I would just say just do your research so that you know that they are growing that hemp as clean as possible.
Next question the area around my affected lymph node is extremely red the large area looks like a strawberry birthmark or a burn or bruise could this be from the right machine i'm wondering if this is a good response or bad.
Well i that's a great question so that's definitely inflamed when it's red like that is that a bad sign it depends upon if you see inflammation as a solely bad thing so inflammation at the site of cancer can be a sign of a heightened immune response.
It can also be a sign of increased cancer activity it's hard to be able to distinguish between the two until you do some form of testing to be able to see what exactly is going on so it could be.
It really could go either way so my recommendation to you is to kind of walk through some of the checks and balances how are you feeling once the last time that you went in for a to a market test are you having any other negative symptoms or positive symptoms.
And do you have the ability to I guess know that's not it.
So things that you can do to support it would be trying to do lymphatic massage lymphatic detox so lymphatic massage lymphatic exercise dry brushing like I had mentioned earlier would help to move that along.
It's hard for me to know exactly what it is that you would that you would have to do i probably have to talk with you and and come up with a couple of other ideas that might be helpful but I would not say I cannot give you a yes or a no as to whether it is a good response or bad response it really depends upon all of the other factors combined.
So if this still leaves you confused or without direction maybe you can set up a phone consultation with me and we can talk through it.
But my recommendation is if you haven't done any recent testing to see if it appears like there is some kind of metastasis or growth happening maybe running your tumor markers again and seeing if there is something that is correlated.
I would say that that's a good way to just see what's going on next question on my AK test they mentioned my liver needing nutritional support I am taking the recommended the recommendation supplement what else can I do diet related since my liver is challenged in getting rid of cancer type debris.
Well diet related no alcohol low sugar.
Dandelion root tea is a great natural way to flesh your liver dandelion tea is a great support we test people for dandelion tea when they're dealing with detox issues or dandelion root extract I should say so drinking dandelion tea is a great source of support I would say just.
Just starting with that plenty of water to be flushing and then if you're looking for other ways to alleviate the burden off of your liver to do the majority of the work anytime you're doing sweating that's going to be helping to alleviate it because then you are removing toxins out of the largest organ on your body your skin and.
Doing things like coffee enemas or caster oil packs caster oil packs over the liver will help to stimulate greater liver function coffee enemas are also going to dump between 90 to 98% of the toxins that are currently in your liver out of your liver so those are great additional support options.
Next question if recommendations are to limit animal protein are eggs included in this is it to limit all eggs fish and meat to four ounces a day all together or can I eat eggs at breakfast fish at lunch and chicken meat at dinner.
Okay so if so we tested for eggs separately so if there should be an indication on your in your binder that says whether or not eggs are recommended if you can have eggs then you can have eggs as normal if you are to limit animal protein and it says to limit eggs then we typically recommend eating meat.
So we're going to try to find out.
Between one to three times a week and eggs one to three times a week so and I don't have a specific size that I recommend you for me to four ounces sounds probably good.
But I.
If all meat and chicken and eggs are limited then I because so it's so it's sectioned out red meat is one poultry is another and eggs is another.
So if it was that you were to limit all three of those indices, then that would be about nine times a week would be sort of your maxing out of eating any one of those foods.
Or a combination of those foods so you could eat red meat about three times in a week poultry about three times in a week and then eggs about three times in a week if that makes sense.
Next question I get very dizzy after the coffee enema and after the son of therapy to the point that I see everything green.
Is this a good sign to prevent it I have increased the coffee enema is to one per day.
That's I get very dizzy after the coffee enema and after the son of therapy.
So the primary combination that coffee enemas or the common theme that coffee enemas and son of therapies would have with each other is that first of all they both aid in detoxification but second of all they both have the potential to eliminate electrolytes.
So I'm getting dizzy after you're doing a coffee enema or after you're doing a sauna, then what could be happening is that it's getting rid of too many electrolytes so I would I would start by going back to am I drinking enough water and adding in with that minerals.
Here in the chat I had typed down clear multi-min plus I would say taking that for sure after each coffee enema and doing each time you do a sauna but I wonder if it's something that you should just start on a regular basis.
I don't know if getting dizzy after a coffee so some people will say they get dizzy after a coffee enema simply because they're sensitive to the caffeine if you're not feeling that caffeine rush but you're legitimately getting dizzy.
It could be because of where you're detoxing from if you're stimulating such a heightened amount of detox it could be that you're almost detoxing neurologically and that can happen as you increase detox throughout the rest of your body then your brain needs to be able to detox as well.
So you could be getting dizzy from that so what you could do is so that you could still continue to do these great therapies is maybe instead of doing them to their full extent maybe reduce the amount.
Let's say you've been in a sauna for a half an hour and after you got out of the sauna after half an hour that's when you were dizzy see if you can handle a sauna for 15 minutes for a coffee enema instead of doing a full court of the coffee maybe do a half of a court of a coffee of coffee and then add in water to make it up to the full court so that you're diluting the sheer amount of caffeine that you're getting the less caffeine that you're getting.
And then stimulate quite a strong of a of a detox in your system so it's possible that that that's it.
And then you could try to dial that back and see if that makes a difference so what if it's detox related what you're having is a herximer reaction which I would say in some sense is a good thing except for the fact that I don't want you to trip and fall.
Dizzy isn't that in and of itself could be a concern but is it that something bad is happening not if it's stimulating detox I just don't want you to overly herx so that you feel sick or can't function if it is mineral related or electrolyte related we can easily remedy that by just adding in some minerals every single day so.
I would start doing both of those I would dial back the sheer amount of the detox that you're doing and then try to increase it from there or or and add in minerals so that we can start to replenish what you may be losing I received a direct question for the past couple of months I have passed what I suspected were small worms but was never sure who this is going to be a fun one.
This last week I saw one that was quite large approximately eight inches I am taking Candaceate forte black saff blood root aloevia immune SBI protect an additional supplements that I was taking prior to working with Conor's clinic I'm excited that this is happening and want to nurture and continue the process do you think my suspicions are correct what could be causing this yes it is correct you are probably peasant worms.
And it's amazing so it's going to be gross and it's going to freak you out but that is awesome the majority of us humans carry parasites we make fantastic hosts and in our very toxic environment that we live in and with our typical American standard diet that we all tend to partake in.
It definitely makes us right for the pickings as far as picking up a parasite so shedding worms after you started a detoxification process is very normal when I first started with doctor Conor's as a patient I passed parasites that I didn't even know existed in this universe they looked like something that was from a different planet like aliens came to earth and then we're residing inside of my body it was horrible but that's a really good.
So your questions do you think my suspicions are correct yes what could be causing this as your body naturally alkalizes itself as you become more in you bring your body back into a greater sense of balance those parasites parasites cannot continue to exist so they exist in a dirty acidic unhealthy environment as you clean yourself up
they can't feed off of anything then so then they end up they tip that it's it's really not going to happen very often that a live worm is going to come out when you use the bathroom it's there typically almost always dead so it's too bad that you don't live locally I have been begging patients who live locally to what if they ever pass the worm put it in a bottle of vodka
and bring it into me because I want to see it I want to see what your body is succeeding to get rid of because that is awesome okay and also so you're already starting to pass these parasites if you if you wanted to take another supplement we do have supplements that are specifically for parasites your body is already ridding yourself of them
but I know that if I was in your shoes I would be looking out what is coming out of my body and going what can I do to get rid of more of these and as rapidly as possible so there are some supplements on our store that help with passing parasites one is called pro vermouth huge
and I'm going to type it into the chat for everyone and pro vermouth huge is a great option for more intestinal worms
if you're thinking that you're dealing with anything with the liver and that would be that would be harder to diagnose typically that something that you'd have to do through testing
but paratocin is another supplement that helps with parasites like liver flukes so it can help to clear potential parasitic infection in the liver
but pro vermouth huge is the ideal one that's actually what we've often recommended if we've had patients who'd like to do kind of an annual cleanse in the spring
if you want to do an annual cleanse in the spring you take several of those every morning until the bottle's gone and that just helps your body to slough off any potential parasites that have taken root throughout the winter months
okay it is 448 just check in the time oh I got another message back from the our our little parasite patient I am equally excited I have pictures if you would like to see yes I do email me pictures send me your worms every time
and maybe this is this is showing my age group but every time somebody tells me they have a parasite I can't help but
here the dumb and dumber line when they are wanting to start a worm company titled I got worms I just think of that every time I love that
okay another question I will have chemo in the next two to three weeks is there anything you recommend to prepare myself for it yes if you are having chemo in the near future then I would have you connect with your liaison to have her send you the chemo protocol
we have two different types of chemo protocols the first chemo protocol is called for intermittent so let's say somebody was going in they go in for an infusion and then three weeks later they go in for another infusion
and so it spread out that's considered intermittent so then we would get you that protocol if you are doing chemo on a daily basis we have a lot of patients who take a daily chemo pill then we would provide you with a different protocol that's tailored to taking the chemo pill daily so get in touch with your liaison and ask her to send you the chemo protocol and she'll be able to get right on that
another question the chemo protocol includes evolve immune if I have Hashimoto's should I avoid this one until I reach at post chemo no I would say your autoimmune system takes a back seat to what's going to happen when you're flooding your veins with mustard gas so I would say do the evolve immune to boost your body
next question should everyone do a parasite cleanse in the spring with program a huge or who should I would say if your body is feeling like you are like you have some extra energy to give
we have some patients that they are at they're doing all that they can to get their supplements in to get their therapies in and they're on a hard road right now I would say that based upon our testing that they should just stick to the basic protocol that we've lined out to lined up for them to be able to give their system they're already maxed out
and so if you feel like you're in a place where you can add in another supplement you can play with that and that's not going to tip you over the edge or overwhelm your system yeah go for it I think it's I think it's very good especially if you have not been eating as clean as you'd like and you've never done one of these before you just want to see if you can flush anything not everybody is going to flush anything they can see
only some of us really special ones that's really extra dirty people myself included are going to flush some something that's pretty big but I think it would be worth it and maybe not even every year you know you could even do it once every few years or something like that but sure if you've got some extra energy to give to it and you feel like you could tolerate another supplement definitely go for it.
Next question you recommended IV vitamin C I'm a bit able to locate them I'm not able to locate them locally at this time can I supplement with regular vitamin C Dr. McCola offers a liposomal one how much would be safe so I can't tell you exactly how much would be your specific dosage to do for liposomal you can totally do liposomal vitamin C if you can't get a whole lot of it.
So that's perfectly fine how much would be I would say if you're going to start liposomal C on your own then I would just follow the recommended dosing on the back of the bottle or if you do a little bit of research into you know what certain clinics have recommended in general sometimes they come out with general protocols if you're going to do liposomal C go by X number of middle leaders per
kilogram of body weight etc but one of the benefits of vitamin C is that is it really it's hard for you to hit levels where you would truly overdose on it.
liposomal is fat soluble so you will hit a limit but I as long as you follow at you know at the very minimum the dosage on the back of the bottle but we've had patients who've doubled tripled and quadrupled that dosage and are perfectly fine.
next question my protocol says daily but I am having weekly doses do I have the right one yeah if you're going in every single week it's probably better for you to just continue with the daily one so your your liaison knew the correct one when you told her what your program was that you were doing.
um your liaison was aware of of the differentiation so we get some people who are doing where they'll go in and they'll they'll do an infusion two three days in a row and then they'll be off for a couple of weeks and then do two three days in a row it's hard because there can be some nuances in there.
um but just know that your liaison is in close communication with me and Dr Connors and so when we knew what your what your program was going to consist of we gave you the one that would probably best suit you you're welcome.
all right it is 454 i've got time for just a couple more questions craving butter or fats so much but no dairy for me.
well if you're craving fats there are all kinds of good fats that are out there so I mean there's avocado there's coconut there's different sorts of nut butters that are available.
I mean there are there are so I mean this was a direct message so some of you didn't see it I received a direct message so there's a lot of option for fats now remember.
remember um when when dairy is a no go for you it so yeah you want to stay away from dairy but again if it's a special occasion don't.
you know you can have a little bit of butter um there are some really great dairy free cheeses that are out there I hope that you're starting to.
you know connect with some of your local co-ops and find some of those cheeses and give them a try they really shouldn't be called cheeses but cheese like items and some of them are really clean.
there are wonderful cashew cheeses that are pretty much just a type of a of a yeast or bacteria that's added and cashews and maybe some herbs and then
they go through this whole process of turning it into this incredible cheese so I would start digging into some of those things and then when you find them by like a flatbed truck full of them and then start eating them on everything because it's
nice when you can find that also olive oil um olive oil makes a really great dipping sauce if you're going to eat some bread uh toast up some bread like they do
over in Europe and make a nice big bowl of of olive oil and grated salt and some pepper and dip that bread in there and enjoy that and get some good fat in that way.
next question can you run your eye on pro wave bath on any of the rife programs like for tonight us.
yes so I have to be very careful to make this point clear and I'm going to type it as I write it you can run any bulb program as a bath program or no as an eye on pro wave let me correct that as an eye on pro wave and I'm going to send that into the chat.
you cannot run any eye on pro wave program as a bulb program there's a big distinction so as we've talked about before eye on pro wave programs the significance of an eye on pro wave program is that um it's higher hurts frequencies
when when might get true rife and his cohort of little engineering geniuses developed their version of a rife machine they wanted to create a generator and a delivery system that had a great deal of stability
so up to about 20,000 hurts you can utilize the bulb and that allows that tesla tube to maintain its stability anything above that and that bulb can be stabilized and it can blow the transistor or can blow a fuse and so that's why they developed the eye on pro wave.
the purpose of the eye on pro wave originally was not to detoxify you through the foot bath it was to be a more stable and effective delivery system for higher hurts frequencies upwards of 2 to 3 million hurts so it's an incredibly effective delivery system so you just want to make sure
that you're not accidentally if you're going to run a bulb program as a bath that you're not then flipping that so that you can run a bath program
on the bulb I hope that makes sense to everybody but yes let's say you have tonight is or let's say um let's say you have a parasite let's say you think you have a parasite and you found a bulb program that seems to be speaking to you
about some kind of fun eight inch long intestinal worm and you want to try to see if you can just stimulate that to a stronger effect you can go ahead and you can run that on a foot bath if you want to
I don't I'm not so sure that the I am you may not pull a worm out of your toe while you're doing the I am pro wave but you can choose to run it as an I as a as a foot bath
is that going to make that program more effective for you uh that's that's to be determined so with every single one of those frequencies that's run on the I am pro wave you have the potential added benefit of having it draw out into the water
if your body hits on a frequency that it's willing to give something up it's not a guarantee but it's a possibility
so if um if you're running that what would normally be a bulb program as a bath and you happen to see a major change
in the water uh that goes beyond just the general light caramel color of the ionization you can certainly do that um
and that that would be a sign that your body really did have something it wanted to give up so uh you could run that for flu programs um
yeah anything like that that's a great great question I just need to make sure that you guys do not run your bath programs on the bulb setting you will blow your transistor
uh okay last question and then I have to get off the chat is there a best order for therapies I am currently doing rife
ion cleanse caster oil packs coffee enemas sonos rebounding dry brushing etc I have heard that doing a foot bath
while doing a sauna session helps the body release toxins or is there a good way to double up to save time like caster oil pack while doing the foot bath
is there an order that will give the best detox results that's a great question um I would say yes you could do
you could do caster oil packs while you do a sauna um and you could do really a caster oil pack pretty much anytime
we have people who do caster oil packing while they sleep at night so an ion cleanse you could probably do an ion
cleanse while you dry brush as far as orders go I had heard so I had heard a patient one time had done research
and I never ended up getting the source that she was reading but what she said is she had been reading that there
was this one doctor who said that you want to do a sauna session and then you follow up the sauna session
with doing a coffee enemma and I thought that was interesting so I thought that I would give that a try
so over this past winter I've been trying to do the combination is that once a week I will do like a big dry
brushing and then I'll go in for a sauna and slough off a bunch of the extra dry skin that's on my body
and then when I get out while I'm still kind of hot and sweating before I jump in the sauna to allow my
body to cool down but without just standing there bored out of my mind until I jump in the shower
I will do a coffee enemma and I can't say that I've noticed some major difference if there is a
percent difference it certainly could be fractional um but I that was what she had studied and so I
thought that I would give it a try I like that sequence I don't think that you have to do it um let's see
what else well I mean you can pretty much be doing anything while you're doing the rife you can
bring the rife machine we have a lot of patients will put their rife machine on a rolling cart
and so if they're going to be cooking dinner and they want to it'll take them an hour and a half to
cook dinner and sit down to eat dinner at their little kitchen table they'll roll the rife machine
into the kitchen queue up a program and they set the ball right there on the counter and there it is
flapping away while they're doing while they're doing their dinner prep their meal prep so I mean
you can you can make everything happen while you're doing the rife machine you could lay it down next to
your yoga mat while you do yoga or exercise we have uh I think another patient who's on this call
she has figured out a way to take the ball and sneak it under the door I think it is of her sauna
so that while she's doing her sauna sessions she has the rife machine the ball right in there
admitting those frequencies while she's doing the sauna so I don't think that there is a bad um
there's a bad combination of ways to do therapies I think if you find ways to be able to double up on them
that seems efficient to you and helps you feel like you're not just having a day in and day out of
doing one therapy after the next um then totally combine them I think that's great and if you happen
to notice that by doing a certain combination of therapies that you feel a lot better or that you've
noticed a better result please send an email in to the clinic and put attention Michelle and let me
know if you notice anything I'm always willing to pass along great data to patients or you know
ask me to make a zoom announcement um and I would be very happy to make an announcement on one of our
zoom calls to be able to share that with other people so that they can continue to benefit I certainly don't
oh you're welcome I certainly don't have all of the answers as far as like what is the best combination
there are probably millions of combinations out there where you could take this drink this
amount of water and then you get into the sauna and then you get out and then you take this certain
supplement and then you do this other therapy I mean I'm sure that there is an entire country club
that is meant to be developed that is just going to take people through all of these amazing therapies
one after the other in perfect research fashion I don't know all of that but I'm always willing to
learn always willing to interact with you guys if you think you've stumbled upon something that
really works or or found a unique way to do therapies that you want to pass along I want to be able to
help all of you as much as possible so all right ladies and gentlemen it's 506 my time it's been
wonderful answering all of your questions thank you so much for participating uh we love all of you
and looking forward to seeing you back here next week take care